so if there's any spirits here in this
room with us now
we ask that you please approach lorraine
come towards the doll
and come and touch her come towards her
and touch her
she'll light up and make a sound
[Music]
so
the best location i've ever investigated
was the true crime museum in hastings
it's a skull that's in there that um
this skull belonged to a french i think
it was an 18th century
french murderer and we had our
echovox running which is like a it's an
app on a phone
um and it chucked out this person's name
the the guy the serial killer and
there's no reason why that name should
have come out
um and it came out in a french accent as
well
and then it said it again and then i
said it did it just said it again
and then it went we so yes in french
literally from the minute we got there
to the minute we started packing up
and left something was going on it
didn't stop
hi we were all in in a one room
um probably no bigger than this studio
and we were all separated we were all
standing in different parts of the room
and out of nowhere i felt
um as if it was happening
you know as if somebody stood right in
front of me
something on my chest pushed me
backwards towards the wall i cannot
think of any reason why i would have
felt something on my chest pushing me
backwards into the wall i took a series
of pictures
in what i believe to be an empty room
and then when i look back at those
images
there's a clear picture there of some
something i can't tell you what it is
and i could not answer why that has
appeared on that picture do you get
scared when something
happens i do he does he never goes first
ever there was an instant not an instant
there was an occasion where we did an
investigation at the london tombs
and something happened we both got
scared
he ran off left no thought for me you
were gone
[Laughter]
okay so this um this is a rem pod it's
emitting an electromagnetic
field around this aerial so if
something approaches and breaks that
electromagnetic field
this will make an audible and visual
signal
now these cause a lot of controversy
so they're commonly known as the ouija
board
we prefer spirit board but i prefer
spirit ball because it doesn't sound
quite so harsh
hollywood have hyped these up massively
to be something of evil to be something
of
opening up gateways to hell and demonic
spirits
it's not it's just another way of
communicating
with the spirit world with the
paranormal with spirit energy
what's the freakiest answer you've had
we did a spirit board session
where i was receiving personal messages
from a loved one on that spirit board
as soon as we established that the
message coming through was for me
and the person that it was i took my
finger off the plant chair you took your
finger off the plan chair and everyone
else around that board
had no connection to me whatsoever so
when i was asking questions
and i was getting intelligent responses
back
for me that was
a game changer because i knew that i was
speaking to my loved one on the other
side
what did that feel like i was in tears
wasn't i yeah i was absolutely balling
my eyes out because
you know as much as i say i'm a true
believer i'm a true believer when you
get something so personal
and you feel like you're having a
conversation and that person is back in
the room again
so yeah i was quite emotional yeah
so this is lorraine
but she's got three faces so she's got
that nice smiley one
she's then got a sleepy one
and then she's got a sad one
we did think that it would be fun if
we would put her down with a bonnet off
and have her
on one of the faces and then ask over
the course of the evening
if spirit could manipulate her and
change her face but it hasn't happened
yet
i think if it did happen i probably
wouldn't use her again
if i'm honest i would be really shy as
well yeah
we contacted a company
who adapted her so that she works as a
rem device so very much like the rem pod
she's got this little box attached to
the back you'll switch her on
and she's got wires underneath the idea
is that you put her down
and you say if there's any spirits here
go and look over there in the corner
there's a nice dolly over there do you
want to go and play
so if anything goes near her because she
gives off that electromagnetic field if
anything goes near her
she'll light up and she'll make a noise
and it did happen at the luggage school
so she was
propped up on one of the old style
wooden desks and there was nobody even
in the room at the time we were in a
room on the other side of the floor
and all of a sudden we could hear that
and we were going
what's that noise and it was only when i
think you turned around and you went
that's lorraine that's the rem doll
going off but she was exactly where we'd
left her
have you ever been felt like you're
mocked for your beliefs i've told my
my colleagues and close friends that we
do this
and they have a little bit of a giggle
but they've all said the same thing and
it's they think we're really brave to
spend our nights
um locked into really dark places really
scary places
and a lot of them have turned on and
said they would never do it not because
they don't believe in it
but because they're not they're too
scared to
witness something or hear something or
see something
we can't prove to you or we can't try to
prove to you or try to change your
opinion
if you don't at least give it a shot but
a lot of people ask you scared
you